jean pierre pernaut et net
[Applaudissements]
merci d'avoir tous les jokers
jean pierre
[Applaudissements]
incertain
je vous laisse dire déjà je voulais te
dire merci parce que tu as toujours été
un amour avec moi même quand j'ai débuté
j'ai pour ça que j'aime beaucoup jean
pire c'est que c'est vrai et dans mes
débuts je venais au grand concours des
animateurs même à l'époque les et les
gens savaient pas qui j'étais et
jambières été le plus sympa avec moi
avec genre y avait des deux jean pierre
jean pierre foucault jean pierre pernaut
pourquoi les autres se séparer de toi
moi que tout en apprenant tunisie'' ya
des personnes qui nous ont contactés
pour adresser un message oui regarde
cher jean pierre
tu as passé toute sa vie à défendre nos
régions notre gastronomie ainsi que le
savoir faire français
et rien pour ça nous sommes tous
reconnaissants et les français doivent
beaucoup
en ce qui nous concerne cela fait 17 ans
que nous nous côtoyons quotidiennement
17 ans que tu es dans la vie comme à
l'écran une personne formidable
généreuse aimante
on te l'a peut-être pas assez dit
message que le plus beau cadeau que la
vie nous est fait c'est de t'avoir comme
père
on t'aime tu as pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bakou
[Musique]
les locaux de la banque une paire de
claquettes et justement refusé les
bonnes mais je prends la boîte vous
prenez vous êtes quand arrivera le jeu
pour touristes
[Rires]
[Musique]
je la vis et des choix cyril vous avez
fait le choix de prendre la boîte et
alors on regarde votre gain cyril je
sais s'allumant cyril ce soir tu as eu
le courage d'ouvrir cette 26ème boîte et
je pense que pas mais après comme tu as
pu le voir avec mon pote juste avant
roland pour pouvoir s'offrir ce soir
comme cadeau d'anniversaire
l'opportunité d'être mon coach pour
roland garros 2020
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et merci à loïc un patricien créatures
marines touraine
c'est le plus beau cadeau qu'on pouvait
le faire il est avec nous
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment un événement que tu sois
légumes ce soir bobby foule
je suis très très heureux de te voir
c'est que maintenant que la paf un
plateau télé si tu l'as dit 18 ans 18
ans et 18 ans pas il est fort parce
qu'il a réussi à me faire revenir sur un
plateau télé c'est incroyable pour moi
j'ai toujours été la plus grande star de
radio de france tout est dit est la plus
grande star de radio depuis des années
des animateurs c'est incroyable ce que
tu fais je suis très fan de toi tu le
sais qui est vraiment devenu un pote
s'est dit je voulais absolument que tu
sois vais pour avec nous pour
l'anniversaire ça se fête
et tu sais qui je crois que tu les
connais pas le shérif comment savoir
déchets des coutumes
merci d'être là les amours et chérie
merci inverse ya une chanson
si réd joie à toi
oh
c'est
m
c'est vrai
chaud
et bien sûr rené maleville bah oui rené
malleville va ici va essayer de faire
gagner beaucoup de sous à une
association qui me tient à coeur
ça s'appelle l'association des papillons
que melville vous êtes un énorme
supporters de l'om c'est très dur c'est
un fait reste un très bon cette artère
de loi alors que tu as des plus grands
super boulot et le voilà malaise pour
faire gagner de l'argent l'association
tu vas devoir porter ton foot est
empêché pour 100 euros pour
l'association les papillons
tu va juste devoir enfiler ce bonnet
paris saint-germain beau c'est là bas ça
ou ça ces cumuls matelas patron d'y
aller mais hors taxes ou il va au petit
inquiète pas voilé la caméra elle est
payée la bagarre allait partout il a
partout si on fait des missions bon
[Applaudissements]
faire n'importe quoi parce que ça c'est
n'importe quoi
attention des hells à 100 euros faire un
tatouage à yoff psg sur le bras non non
ça ça semble sa samba sy va être
contrainte à toi tu vas acheter un
maillot du paris saint germain
allez allez marseillais
une sale soirée j'espère en tout comme
koné que c'est pour une association pour
les abattoirs 5 0 c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
et on fera toujours en direct et on
continuera à dire des conneries je vous
le dis quitte à voir le csa sur le dos
des critiques sur twitter ou autre en
tout cas de mon émission dont on est
fier ici tous ensemble et c'est vrai
qu'on est fiers de touche pas à mon
poste c'est un énorme succès depuis onze
ans et c'est grâce à vous les chéris ce
soir je vous le dis vous êtes tous en
blanc tout le public et ce soir on va
tous partir ensemble puisque c'est mon
anniversaire je vous amène tous au
restaurant le moment les cherry l'a dit
malheureusement je ne suis pas là ah oui
car c'est le jour du grand pardon qu'on
appelle communément le yom kippour ça
donc je ne serais pas là tant donné que
je ne serai pas là il ya deux émissions
animées oui et on s'est dit par un souci
d'équité on a des tire au sort avec
cette roue de l'animation
sa lé bella huawei franchement ce n'est
pas le c qui pour ces le sait pour qui
attention c'est parti on y va aller
[Musique]
c'est bernard baud
[Applaudissements]
sur tes potes ou tué
à l'arrivée un bravo la roue alors
d'avancis larmes n'est pas truquée je
vais relancer la roue maintenant aux
alors qu'il va animer tous moi mon fils
est encore bernard montiel
oui j'ai une préférence rené malleville
pas mollir gaulle à la même moi je suis
capable de casser l'outil cours je casse
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon cas
si vous faites
ou être qu'elle savait ce que vous
faites voilà vous aviez à prendre ou à
laisser comme c'est vous qui avait été
choisi par la roue d'accord dans un
instant vous allez me dire qu'ils vous
choisissez pour annie n'était plus aux
nouvelles villes où il abat liberté je
le dis maintenant tout à l'heure on a
choisi toi c'est dire la vérité tacle
rugueux n'importe qui n'importe qui à
n'importe qui je dis rené malleville
ambulants leurs mains nues ratez pas
[Applaudissements]
vellaye mais benhaim qui est quand même
à l'ancienne un cas deux cent cinquante
ans il me dit j'enregistre elle encore
avec son magnétoscope
[Musique]